[Laughter]
companies of all shapes and sizes
across industries and geographies have
dramatically accelerated the adoption of
digital during 2020.
as a result digital transformation
journeys have been forced to accelerate
over this period with years of
transformation being pushed forward
within just a few months
as apis are the fundamental building
blocks of any digital transformation
program we had google cloud set out to
better understand the ways in which
enterprises have tracked
deployed monitored and managed apis in
2020
after careful investigation of this data
we published a very insightful report
that speaks to the state of api economy
in 2021
this report brings together an in-depth
analysis of over 2 trillion api
calls to better understand usage
behavior on the apigee api management
platform
the detailed study of customer use cases
seen across geos and industries in 2020
and findings from a survey administered
to over 700 technology leaders from
enterprises around the world
let's take a look at the findings during
the last year
despite the pandemic nearly 75 percent
of companies studied continued focusing
on their digital transformation
initiatives
and almost two-thirds of those companies
actually increased their investments and
efforts
we also saw a perfect correlation
between the growth of api traffic on
apogee
and increased investments in digital
transformation programs
just in 2020 apogee saw a whopping 46
percent year-over-year api traffic
growth
with traffic volume hitting an all-time
high of 2.2 trillion calls
with heightened levels of api usage
security and privacy of apis were of
utmost importance to enterprises
as a result anomaly detection bot
protection and security analytics usage
grew by over 230 percent across apigee
customers
and api analytics adoption increased by
over 75
among apigee customers api security
api analytics and api traffic are just
some of the ways enterprises are
investing in their api programs as they
work to accelerate their digital
transformation programs
if you want to learn about other areas
of investment then the state of api
economy report is the perfect place to
start you can download the executive
summary here
at goo dot go slash exact sum state of
apis
or download the full state of api
economy report here
at goo dot go state of apis if you want
to talk to a cloud value advisor about
the report
and what the findings mean to your
enterprise then ping us at
cloud.google.comcontact
we hope you enjoyed the report and we
look forward to connecting with you at
the earliest